salut aujourd'hui je sors des magic tuto
vous savez c'est le spectacle on vous
avait parlé avec bonnafé jean sébastien
massé il est là aujourd'hui je vous
présente jf
bonjour à tous j'ai c'est un vrai ami
magicien et quand j'ai écrit le
spectacle des magic tuto avec bonaf j'ai
tout de suite pensé à toi à l'époque
pour tenir ce rôle
et aujourd'hui je vous ai vu sur scène
c'était mortel un match qui remercie
donc vous savez en ce moment j'aime bien
deux fois pendant un petit peu de un
petit peu de vacances surtout quand j'ai
quelqu'un de très talentueux avec moi et
j s comme c'est un grand magicien j'ai
demandé qu'ils me fassent un tour de
magie vraiment y'a pas du pipeau talent
je sais pas ce qui va me faire
j'espère que je vais de bluffer si je
vois un truc je vous le dis bien tester
ton imagination à ce que tu penses avoir
une imagination
oui car je veux davantage que tu veux
alors je le plus tôt prendre celle ci
comme qu'il est à présent de toute façon
c'est bon je sais moi je tire toi
ap à l'écran l'image
le jeu
fabien tu imagines invite à quel degré
sur l'échelle de jeu pense vraiment être
à neuf parce que vous savez tout ce que
je fais avec la mémoire c'est souvent en
visualisant avec l'imaginaire donc je
pense vraiment avoir beaucoup
d'imagination je crois en toi j'aime à
le croire ok alors on va tester
simplement avec le temps ces trois très
bons retours que le trois trèfles et ma
carte préférée à d'accord mais je
demande et c'est simplement donné je me
suis dit c'est pas bon du tout conforme
à la tendreté revenir là dessus car
pause et on m'a par dessus les imaginer
que sous le thème un trait de transport
tout doucement nouvelle qualité il
suffit d'imaginer
l'image transforme doucement pour
l'image de ta carte
cette transformation avec des noirs ce
que la concernant
ça te permet de partager ton imagination
avec moi comme avec vous de telle sorte
que nous avons tous être capable vidéo
interposée de voir sa carte
ceux qui le voient en moi et c'est ma
carte cette valve une pique
évidemment
l'imagination d'accord je t'avais miné
par la carrière poser ta main dessus a
pris fin dans cette carte c'est le droit
de rêve non
ça c'est le ballet mixage c'est le
troisième mais notre imagination à tous
nous fait croire que c'est le valais dit
m
et là vous vous dites que je franchisse
pour des jambons alors vous avez un
objectif à la fois car cette carte
passive à ce qu on se rend compte
effectivement là je votais le 3°
quelques douze coups voire depuis le
début n'était que pure imagination
voyage c'est à dire que si moi je veux
que ça devienne un 5 2 peak qui pensent
qu'en leur second j'arrive à transiger
l'imagination de devenir franchement pas
où je me dis c'est un vieux kikson2
pixon de pique
là ça devient 102
j'arrive deux fois d'affilée soit ce
qu'était un bon mètre en fait avec toi
qui aimes mâcon la faire ça c'est ouf ou
parce qu'il fait mon pote js on est à
côté des toilettes d'un restaurant il ya
des gens qui passent mais rodin bizarre
mais on les voit derrière on a misé
autres commerces
c'est un total de six doublettes à nous
rendez vous demain à 11h au prochain
modèle blog ciao